moi j'ai travaillé une vingtaine
d'années dans les au ministère de la
Défense français sur différentes
domaines qui tout tout sauf de
l'administration c'est-à-dire affaires
stratégiques exportation d'armement
renseignement et d'une manière générale
réflexion sur l'organisation du
ministère poste que j'ai quitté au début
des années 2000 pour diriger une société
intelligence économique pendant environ
8 ans maintenant ça va je suis retraité
heureux parce que je peux faire ce que
j'ai envie de faire c'est-à-dire en fait
écrire je suis libéré de la parole si
vous voulez bonjour Pierre conessa
bonjour Nous vous intervion aujourd'hui
pour une chaîne Youtube qui s'appelle
Serview on aurait voulu discuter un
petit peu de l'Arabie Saoudite qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire à l'heure
actuelle au vu de l'actualité les câbles
Wikileak qu'est-ce que vous en pensez le
l'Arabie Saoudite est un pays absolument
magnifique c'est une espèce de
Disneyland de l'islam c'est-à-dire que
tout est faux
c'està-dire vous avez des gens qui
croient qu'il pratiquent une religion et
qui la pratiquent pas les ils arrivent à
tout interdire c'est-à-dire il y a pas
de il y a pas de cinéma il y a pas de
bibliothèque il y a pas de théâtre il y
a rien du tout puisque tout ça
évidemment détourne de la religion mais
paradoxalement quand les Saoudiens sont
à l'étranger tout à coup ils deviennent
de véritables voyou ils se payent des
prostitués ils boivent de l'alcool et
cetera puis ensuite quand il rentrent au
pays ben il faut qu'il donne font de
gros dons à des organisations
humanitaires qui vont en général
financer daesh voilà donc c'est un pays
assez étonnant dans sa dans sa structure
soci
après WikiLeaks les câbles WikiLeaks bah
c'està-dire que les les câbles de
Wikileak n'ont fait que révéler une
chose qu'on qu'on qu'on subodorait enfin
dont on pensait qu'effectivement elle
était elle était assez systématique mais
on en avait pas de de preuve bien
évidente c'est-à-dire que l'Arabie
Saoudite est un pays qui est un qui est
un un pays magique puisque finalement le
niveau de vie par tête doit être
probablement le plus élevé de la planète
mais essentiellement parce que c'est
unnorme producteur de pétrole et donc
que qui a une diplomatie du carnet de
chèque pour acheter des élites dans un
certain nombre de pays n'est pas en soi
très étonnant cela dit on peut
effectivement faire du carnet de chque
direct ou on peut faire des intérêts
communs si vous voulez genre la famille
bouche avec la famille Benladen par
exemple donc encore une fois c'est
Wikileak a révélé des choses qu'on
subodoré mais en apportant des preuves
précises quoi au Maroc au Liban et
cetera P est-ce que vous pouvez
développer un petit peu la position avec
Ben Laden la famille Ben Laden la
famille buou non la famille Ben Laden
n'est pas en soi un sujet d'intérêt
parce que d'abord c'est une énorme
famille donc qu'il y ait dedans des gens
qui soient proches de Mohamed le
terroriste ou qu'il y a des gens qui so
qui s'appellent aussi Mohammed Ben Laden
et qui a rien à voir avec lui c'est une
réalité il y a un avocat d'ailleurs
francophone qui porte exactement le même
nom et qui en fait est un avocat
d'affaires parfaitement respectable donc
la famille Ben Laden c'est pas une
totalité c'est une entité hétérogène
celui qui nous intéresse évidemment
c'est celui qui évidemment a été emporté
notre notre affection il y a quelques
années
donc ce qui est intéressant c'est pas le
fait que la famille Ben Laden c'est
surtout le fait que quand on a eu les
attentats du 11 septembre on sait bien
que le gouvernement américain a autorisé
ce qui vivait de famille Ben Laden aux
États-Unis à s'en aller discrètement bon
mais le tour de pass-p le plus
prodigieux de l'Arabie Saoudite c'est
quand même le fait que quand le 11
septembre je vous coupe je vous coupe ce
tour de pass-pe l'exfiltration de la
famille Ben Laden quand l'espace aérien
américain était fermé c'est ça ouais
c'est ça exactement donc non le tour de
passe-p le plus étonnant et qui qui
finalement est magnifique dans son dans
sa réalisation c'est le fait qu'il y a
11 saoudiens sur 19 terroristes dans les
attentats du 11 septembre et que 2 mois
plus tard George buou énonce que les
pays de l'Axe du mal c'est l'IRAC l'Iran
et la Corée du Nord et il évite
soigneusement l'Arabie Saoudite donc ça
c'est un tour de passe-p stratégique
auquel je regrette que les Européens se
soient prêtés en silence puisque quand
même c'était un c'était une évidence que
ce pays était déjà vérolé par le
terrorisme à cause de sa pratique de
l'Islam et que arrivit à l'éviter pour
ne pas toucher à des intérêts
économiques commerciaux pétroliers et
cetera était quand même une escroquerie
intellectuelle et stratégique encore une
fois auquel des gouvernants de l'époque
mais enfin on était dans les mois du 11
septembre donc c'était difficile de
critiquer euh le gouvernement américain
le résultat on l'a vu c'est que il y a
eu l'invasion de l'Irak dont on n
toujours pas dont les conséquences se
continuent encore aujourd'hui alors vous
vous parliez de la la diplomatie du du
Carn TCK est-ce qu'on voit un petit peu
euh la diplomatie religieuse du carnet
tchèque par chez nous dans le monde
entier qu'est-ce qui se passe oui
l'autre aspect qui me paraît très
intéressant c'est la diplomatie
religieuse de l'Arabie Saoudite parce
que la diplomatie du carnet tèque à la
limite c'est de la diplomatie classique
hein c'est ce que faisait Moutou aussi
pour rester au pouvoir c'est-à-dire
qu'il payit à droite et à gauche pour
pouvoir être sûr que les élections ne
perturbent pas sa dictature non ce qui
est le plus intéressant c'est que à
partir de 73 l'Arabie saoudite à cause
de la du boom pétrolier des prix du
pétrole va toucher en 3 jours ce qu'elle
touchait en 1 an et se trouve donc à la
tête d'une masse financière gigantesque
et pour bien comprendre le régime
saoudien il faut savoir que c'est un
régime politico-rigieux hein
c'est-à-dire que c'est l'alliance des
wahabites enfin les disciples d'abal
Wahab et de la famille seou qui vont
faire ce régime saoudien bon et donc à
la tête de cette fortune immense qui qui
explose à partir de 73 se développe une
diplomatie religieuse qui dans le cadre
de l'islam va essentiellement consister
à développer la pratique saoudienne de
l'islam c'estàd éïiste cette pardon la
plus rigoriste oui la plus rigoriste
c'estàd celle qui coupe les mains des
voleurs qui décapit qui opprime les
femmes et qui interditent les autres
religions donc je veux dire ces critères
là il faut les retenir parce qu'on va
les retrouver ailleurs et donc et par
hasard et par extraordinaire aussi quand
les les disciples d'Abdel Wahab arrivent
et prennent la mec en même temps qu'sou
ils détruisent le cimetière dans lequel
sont enterrés les compagnons du Prophète
c'est pour dire que c'est des rigoristes
au sens où il y a que l'adoration de
Dieu même les compagnons du Prophète
leurs tombes ne sont même pas sont
considérés commê P parce que ça pourrait
développer un culte dessin donc dans ce
grand humanisme qui est la pratique
saoudienne de la de l'islam donc va
essayer de va diffuser va être diffusé
un peu partout sur la planète avec des
moyens financiers gigantesques
c'est-à-dire que on crée des madrassas
donc des écoles coraniques on distribue
des Bours on distribue des bouquins on
on distribue des bourses pour des
étudiants qui veulent venir en Arabie
Saoudite vendre le Coran on donne
évidemment très largement la version la
traduction saoudienne du Coran ce qui
est pas tout à fait la même que d'autres
traductions et donc autour de ces foyers
dans des pays cette stratégie est
planétaire c'est ça qui est très
étonnant c'est-à-dire que ça vient
évidemment ici on a eu pas mal d'imam
Saoudiens qui nous ont été fournis en
même temps que la construction de
mosquée et donc par contre ce qu'on n
pas eu raison de regarder c'est ce qui
se passait ailleurs en Afrique
sub-saharienne où on a vu par exemple au
Mali qu' avait des
salafistes ils ont on a été surpris
qu'il y en a on en a vu en RCA on en
voit au Niger au Nigéria et cetera et
cetera et donc cette stratégie était
planétaire mais on l'a pas surveillé
parce que notre réseau diplomatique n'a
pas vocation à surveiller les évolutions
des cultes musulmans dans les pays où il
est installé que que faisait la DGSE
mais la DGSE ne s'occupait pas de ça
c'est-à-dire que on était à partir de 79
la donne stratégique est complètement
transformé et surtout l'Arabie Saoudite
devient un allié essentiel dans pour
deux raisons d'abord parce que début 79
il y a la Révolution iranienne la
révolution iranienne c'est une
révolution démocratique ça personne ne
doute si vous voulez ensuite on pense
qu'on veut du régime mais en tout cas
les gens étaient dans la rue et les
Saoudiens sont tétanisés à l'idée queil
puisse y avoir un régime politique
chiite non arabe qui s'installe à leur
porte et qui puisse prétendre prendre le
leadership sur la communauté musulmane
donc ça c'est un choc terrible mais ils
ont une opportunité formidable qui est
fait que à fin 79 même année les
Soviétiques envahissent l'Afghanistan et
donc à ce moment-là ils vont prendre la
tête du djihad c'est à ce moment-là que
ressort le terme pour aller combattre
les mécréan c'estàdire les Soviétiques
qui pour eux sont dans la même catégorie
que les Occidentaux hein simplement
effectivement il y en a qui sont les
bons il y en a qui sont les méchants
mais tous sont sont des mécréants et
donc il va y avoir le soutien aux
Afghans résistants à l'Union soviétique
et une grande participation de beaucoup
de saoudiens d'ailleurs à cette guerre
on pense que à peu près 70 % des
combattants étranger à l'époque sont
viennent de d'Arabie Saoudite alors se
passe à ce moment-là un processus là
aussi qu'on n pas vu arriver c'est que
parmi les conditions mises par le prince
tourquy le chef des services de
renseignement par lequel transitait
l'aide pour les PIST pour les Afghans il
va imposer au régime du Maréchal Zia qui
est un régime islamiste mais amateur si
vous voulez par rapport au saoudien il
va lui imposer l'ouverture de madrasa
donc d'école coranique version où habite
et puis avec tout ce qui va avec les
bourses les les bouquins les bibliothèqu
les machins et Cera et le produit final
qu'on va voir sortir c'est les talibans
taliban étymologiquement c'est les
étudiant religion c'est-à-dire ces gens
qui vont tout à coup raser tout ce qu'il
trouvent sur leur passage qui vont déjà
mettre en œuvre ce qu'on trouve
aujourd'hui à daesh ou ce qui est
régulièrement pratiqué en Arabie
Saoudite c'est-à-dire la lapidation des
femmes la décapitation et cetera et
cetera donc pour les homosexuels ils ont
fait preuve d'inventivité puisqueils
estimaient que les homosexuels il
fallait les écraser il fallait que
bulldozer écrase un mur sur eux donc ils
étaient quand même assez novateurs les
talibans dans la dans la répression donc
le simultanément autre épisode aussi en
Algérie vous avez 10 années de guerre
civile où vous avveit des salafistes les
les groupes islamiques armé les GIA puis
ensuite le GSPC le groupe salafiste pour
la prédication et le combat qui vont
massacrer d'autres musulmans en Algérie
ça a fait plus quand même plus de 100
100 à 150000 morts on sait pas très bien
mais encore une fois tout ça ce sont des
conséquences indirectes de ce djihad qui
au départ était tourné contre les
mécréants et puis qui progressivement va
se tourner contre les régimes arabes
mais créant c'est-à-dire les régimes de
mauvais musulmans mauvais mauvais
musulmans parce que peut-être à la botte
des pays occidentaux ou instrumentalisé
par les pays occidentaux ou jugé comme
instrumentalisé par les pays occidentaux
c'est un mélange de plusieurs choses
c'est-à-dire que les salafistes
considèrent d'abord que le principe
constitutionnel qui soit dictatorial ou
qui soit démocratique de toute façon
prétendrait su comment dire rendre
supérieure la loi des hommes à par
rapport à la loi de Dieu donc il y a pas
besoin de constitution dans un régime
salafiste du moment qu'on applique la
charia et qu'on qu'on suit le Coran
qu'on va chercher toutes les questions
dans le Coran à ce moment-là on se il y
a même pas besoin de savoir si le régime
est mécrain ou pas puisque le régime ne
doit pas exister bon et donc qu' soit
alliés des Occidentaux qui le Soi pas
c'est-à-dire ils vont se battre contre
le père Assad par exemple avec une
insurrection les Frères musulmans en
particulier mais qui va être réprimé
dans le sang par le père Assad dans la
ville de Hama mais ils vont se battre de
la même façon contre le régime algérien
qui se prétend successeur de la guerre
d'indépendance et cetera donc encore une
fois c'est pas la base alliance
occidentale ou pas c'est la contestation
de leur légitimité comme gouvernant et
donc encore une fois tout doit être
dicté par le le Coran par exemple
épisode rigolo quand il y a eu l'affaire
Clinton Monica levinski par exemple hein
que il s'était fait faire une F par une
stagiaire il y a eu un débat sur aljzira
qui est une radio qatarie qui est une
télé Catarie sur le thème est-ce que la
fation est halal ou pas avec des des
docteurs en théologie he qui venaient
donner leur avis notamment pendant la
période du Ramadan POS une question
importante parce que vous voyez bien le
problème technique que ça pose et donc
il y a eu c'est ce genre de chose
c'est-à-dire l'idée qu'on a dans une
lecture littéral du Coran réponse à tout
même peut-être sur internet ils vont
trouver demain des des questions des
réponses aussi donc encore une fois
c'est cette pratique là c'est-à-dire la
plus obscurantiste et cette diplomatie
religieuse en 35 ans c'est à peu près
500 mosquées qui sont ouvertes avec des
fonds saoudiens 1500 mosquées ça
commence à faire pas mal 1500 mosquées
en France ou non non sur le l'ensemble
de l'action de la planète parce que
cette action est quand même un peu
partout sur le sur la planète encore une
fois beaucoup en Afrique en Asie
beaucoup aussi pas mal en pas mal en
Russie à partir de 91 il y a M
aujourd'hui des islamistes au Tatarstan
il évidemment au Caucase et cetera et
cetera donc c'est cette vision
planétaire qu'on a eu beaucoup de mal à
à surveiller puisque finalement chacun
de ses postes n'avait pas se demander ce
que faisait l'Arabie Saoudite il aurait
fallu une impulsion politique en disant
mais qu'est-ce que fait l'Arabie
Saoudite dans ces différents endroits et
là on entre dans un débat qui est
beaucoup plus général c'est-à-dire
comment les Occidentaux se sont-ils
comportés vis-à-vis de ce régime alors
par exemple Richard Baher le patron de
la un des patron de du renseignement
américain raconta que pendant longtemps
il était interdit de faire du
renseignement sur l'Arabie Saoudite
interdit
c'est interdit sur l'Arabie Saoudite
mais en France on peut ah oui oui oui
bien sûr bien sûr non mais encore une
fois le le vetto était venu pour des
raisons politiques pas pour des raisons
stratégiques c'est-à-dire que ils
avaient peur qu'un incident diplomatique
un type se fasse prendre et par partir
de ce moment-là toute sanction
commercial tout ce qu'on peut imaginer
mais je veux dire la lâcheté stratégique
que ça représente est assez gigantesque
je sais pas ce qu'il en était pour les
Français mais enfin en tout cas pour les
Américains on a eu confirmation que
c'était interdit vous parlez de de
l'acheter euh à l'heure actuelle est-ce
que vous pensez que la position du
gouvernement français vis-à-vis de la
l'Arabie Saoudite est une position de
lâche bah c'estàdire que le on se trouve
dans cette situation étonnante où on est
en train de faire la guerre à daesh pour
des
raisons qui sont assez évidentes hein on
a décapité des types on coupe les mains
des voleurs on opprime les femmes on
interd autres religions donc si vous il
vous manque une case il faut la remplir
si parce que en fait vous parlez de
l'Arabie Saoudite vous parlez de daesh
l'Arabie Saoudite c'est pareil VO et
donc on en arrive à se battre contre da
d'une manière qui d'ailleurs dans sa
motivation est assez scandaleuse quand
vous avez des sites de jeunes islamistes
en France et qui vous disent 12 morts à
Gaza on fait rien qu occidentaux égorgés
on envoie l'armée on peut comprendre
qu'ils soit scandalisé par une
diplomatie de double standard comme ça
bref on se retrouve à se battre à côté
des Américains contre daesh régime pour
lequel on peut ne pas n'avoir aucune
sympathie hein mais pour défendre celui
qui a donné naissance c'est-à-dire
l'Arabie Saoudite ça fait un peu comme
dans le roman de Marie Chelle
c'est-à-dire que le docteur Frank
Einstein voudrait bien qu'on le
débarrasse de son monstre son monstre
mais dans le le roman il disparaît en
même temps que lui tandis que nous on
voudrait que le monstre soit disparaisse
mais pas le géniteur donc c'est à côté
un côté un peu cocasse un exemple si
vous voulez quand on regarde la
structure des forces qui se bombardent
daesh aujourd'hui les Saoudiens ont deux
fois moins d'avion que les Français et
par contre ils en ont deux fois plus que
pour se battre au Yemen contre les
chiites euh ils ont autant d'avions que
les Danois et les hollandais a additionn
bon on a quand même un peu l'impression
que ça ressemble à une croisade quand on
est du côté des sunites et donc on a
fait la bêtise qu'il fallait provocation
terroriste réaction et évidemment
maintenant on est dans un système où
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de des
déclarations de Manuel Vals
concernant cette guerre de civilisation
oh je je pense c'est une déclaration de
les moi c'est-à-dire qu'il a voulu
marquer par un propos à mon avis exagéré
en tout cas qui traduit pas la réalité
que il y avait quelque chose qui
interpelit si vous voulez la nos
sociétés bon je rappelle quand même si
en fait c'est perçu comme une croisade
ah bah c'est perçu par eux comme une
croisade de toute façon donc c'est ça
qui est important parce que le le
difficulteté du sujet c'est que quand
des Occidentaux disent croisad ça a une
connotation positive alors que pour les
musulmans ça a une connotation très
négative puisque c'est l'action
impérialiste par nature et quand nous on
parle de djihad par nature c'est une
intention agressive alors que pour les
musulmans ça peut être une espèce de
discipline personnelle pour s'améliorer
bon et donc les termes ont un double
sens et ce qui fait que même si on parle
pas de croisade c'est pris comme une
croisade par eux et même si eux ne
parlent pas de Jihad on va le prendre
pour le jihad même quand ça n'est pas
donc le la déclaration de Manuel Vals
elle s'est faite dans les mois
évidemment d'une décapitation mais si on
y réfléchit bien il y a eu quand même
une cinquantaine de morts dans une
mosquéchite au kouweit il y a eu 37
morts en Tunisie sur une plage et il y a
eu un homme décapité en France l'ordre
des ennemis pour daesh c'est pas celui
de la France c'est les chiides d'abord
parce que ce sont les musulmans
dissidents et cetera ce sont les
catégories des mauvais musulmans
c'est le 3ème attentat sur une mosquée
chiite dans la région de en Arabie
Saoudite le trème au kite imaginez une
minute qu'on mette une bombe dans une
mosquée ici vous voyez le scandale que
ça provoquerait ça ne choque même pas la
communauté musulmane ici c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a une espèce d'empathie si vous
voulez vis-à-vis de ce qui se passe
là-bas comme si les chiites étaient des
gens méprisables qu'il faillaient
massacrer deuxième caractéristique le
tourisme donc en Tunisie c'està-dire
contre le régime démocratique arabe on
revient dans la logique qu'on évoqué
tout à l'heure et 3è épisode seulement
celui de cette ce type en en iser qui va
tenter de faire exploser un S de ses
vaiseaux mais avec beaucoup de bricolage
donc le le coût du du l'acteur solitaire
si vous voulez c'est à la fois le risque
il est très difficile de contre lequel
il est très difficile de se prémunir
puisque ça peut être n'importe où
n'importe quand mais l'avantage de de
cet inconvénient c'est que le type ne
peut pas monter un système trop
compliqué c'est-à-dire qu'il ne peut pas
imaginer de faire un attentat organisé
parce que tous les systèmes de
surveillance démontent un réseau de donc
il a la fragilité de l'avantage si vous
voulez vous avez parlé d'un d'un agenda
d'un d'un calendrier de de de prise de
position par par daesh Israël dans le
calendrier ça se trouve entre les pays
arabes la France dans la stratégie de DA
non c'est pas c'est pas Israël c'est les
Juifs c'est les Juifs c'est le c'est un
terme générique hein euh c'est-à-dire
pour eux c'est la théorie du complot les
Juifs sont
partout alors par exemple ce qui est
très cocasse si vous voulez c'est que
quand vous regardez un des principaux
ressort de la mobilisation de la
conversion que les salafistes arrivent à
exercer sur Internet c'est la thématique
la méthodologie des secte de
l'Apocalypse c'est-à-dire la fin du
monde est pour bientôt et donc si vous
devenez un bon croyant pendant le court
lapse de temps qui vous reste à vivre à
ce moment là vous avez des chances
d'échapper à l'enfer et cetera
thématique qu'on avait chez les Témoins
de Jéhova qu'on avait chez Jim Jones
qu'on avait chez d'autres mais eux c'est
l'annonce de l'Apocalypse appuyé sur la
réalité historique puisque la guerre en
Syrie c'était selon eux ce qu'avait
annoncé le prophète
donc on se retrouve dans un système où
la comment dire dans cette pureté exigée
pour atteindre l'Apocalypse dans les
meilleures conditions il y a
l'élimination de tous ceux qui vont vous
entraver c'est-à-dire c'est une théorie
générale du complot dans lequel il y a
les mauvais musulmans qui peuvent
commencer par la famille ensuite il y a
effectivement tous ceux qui par nature
sont comment dire des traîtres à l'islam
il faut penser que par exemple euh
khalet Kelkal vous savez qui était le
type qui était qui a été buté dans la
région lyonnaise il était à l'origine
des attentats de Saint-Michel de de
Luxembourg en 94 93 94 93 bon il avait
été interviewé par un sociologue
allementand 1 an avant quand il était un
jeune type de la des Minguettes et il
disait le chiisme a été inventé par les
Juifs pour diviser l'islam c'est-à-dire
qu'il arrivait à rendre les Juifs même
responsable du chisme et donc cette
accusation générique contre les Juifs
c'est tout Juif est par nature mauvais
d'où l'attitude de Mera avec les enfants
de l'écolearatora c'est d'où l'attitude
du super cacher et cetera et donc c'est
pas Israël parce que Israël c'est trop
difficile pour c'est inaccessible donc
il faut prendre au niveau de la lecture
de de la stratégie est-ce que vous
pensez que daesh pratique la stratégie
de l'anaconda c'està-dire la stratégie
de l'encerclement d'Israël pour ensuite
serrer ses anneaux non je crois pas
d'abord parce que il est pas au contact
d'Israël au contraire même il est au
contact de du de l'armée de Bagdad de
l'armée de Assad il est au contraire
comment dire enfermé dans une guerre
encore une fois religieuse interne à
l'islam les massacres aujourd'hui sont
des massacres intra musulmans quand on
regarde les statistiques du terrorisme
par exemple aujourd'hui par exemple les
bases américaines le terrorisme
aujourd'hui tue 10 fois plus de
musulmans que de non musulmans ça veut
dire que encore une fois là où on pense
qu'il y a un acte terroriste dont la
logique politique est de s'opposer à
nous non la logique politique de ce
terrorisme là c'est d'exterminer les
mauvais musulmans d'abord et donc les
soufi donc les chiites donc les mauvais
musulmans donc les malékites et de
détruire tous les signes de ces
pratiques ignoble quand les salafistes
arrivent au Mali ils commencent par
détruire les bibliothèques les
bibliothèques malquites comme l'avaient
fait les talibans d'autres temps comme
l'a fait le GSPC en Algérie donc il y a
une espèce de matrice idéologique si
vous voulez qui est de même nature que
celle de l'Arabie Saoudie c'est celle
qu'elle a diffusé un peu dans touses
madrassa et encore une fois l'ordre des
ennemis n'est pas celui qu'on imagine
donc la question politique c'est faut-il
intervenir dans une guerre de religion
voyez ma question c'est que quand on
arrive dans une guerre de religion et
qu'à forceorie on naappartient pas à
cette religion qu'est-ce qu'on est on
est un
croisé on va revenir sur l'Arabie
saoudite à notre
époque vos préconisations si vous aviez
les commandes ben d'abord il y a une
préconisation essentielle c'est qu'on
peut pas se battre à la place des autres
c'est-à-dire on est parti comme ça au
moment des décapitations mais sans
aucune conditionnalité politique c'està
dire on va reprocher à daesh qui se
pratique régulièrement en Arabie
Saoudite et ne pas oublier que l'Arabie
Saoudite vient de lancer un appel à
propos un appel à candidat candidature
parce qu'il manque de bourreaux ils
veulent recruter h bourreaux
donc c'est ce pays-là qu'on va essayer
de défendre autre exemple si vous voulez
d'actualité il y a un jeune type qui
s'est permis sur son blog de dire que la
police religieuse avait des pouvoirs
excessifs en Arabie Saoudite il a été
condamné à 10 ans de prison et 1000
coups de fouet 1000 coups de fouet bon
il s'appelle Rayf Badaoui je n'ai pas vu
de pétition de BHL ou de qui que ce soit
sur le sujet bon peu importe le000
coup de fouet le type il fera jamais ses
10 ans de prison il sera mort avant et
je n'ai jamais entendu une quelconque
critique contre le système saoudien d'un
quelcon comme politique français on va
donner des leçons à la planète entière
on va expliquer que Poutine est un
horrible dictateur et que évidemment
sijin Ping le chinois et lui aussi fait
des camps de concentration et CEA mais
jamais on a levé le moindre sourcil pour
dire au saoudien c'est pas bien or quand
on est dans une guerre et qu'on défend
ce régime là on peut quand même poser
quelques conditionnalité politique
est-ce que vous pensez que on ne
critique pas l'Arabie Saoudite parce que
l'Arabie Saoudite est la tête de pont
américaine dans la région non je crois
pas je crois que il y a il y a des il y
a des logiques françaises et américaines
qui sont un peu différentes vis-à-vis de
l'Arabie Saoudite la logique américaine
effectivement est aujourd'hui quand même
de se libérer le plus possible de la
dépendance énergétique saoudienne et s
ils y réussissent avec le le gaz de
schist avec le pétrole de schist les
Français sont dans une dépendance
commerciale très importante à l'égard de
l'Arabie Saoudite et on fait terire
toutes les critiques avec la perspective
de de 10 milliards de signature de
contrat bon moi depuis que je travaille
sur l'Arabie Saoudite il y a toujours 10
milliards en instance donc ça le chiffre
ne m'intéresse pas tellement ça se
réalise rarement les 10 milliards d'un
coup mais enfin je fais remarquer que
dans les contrats en négociation on vend
deux centrales nucléaires pr à l'Arabie
Saoudite et que visiblement en Iran dès
qu'il commence à développer du nucléaire
même de technologie assez classique on
trouve ça très inquiétant dans un pays
qui n'a aucun tissu industriel comme
l'Arabie Saoudite qui n'a aucun comment
dire de sociologie de l'ingéniering de
ce genre de sujet
je comprends pas la logique qui va
entretenir ce ces centrales et surtout
qui va les surveiller on leur a vendu un
laboratoire P4 un laboratoire P4 c'est
les laboratoires extrêmement sécurisés
dans lesquels en particulier on
travaille contre les armes chimiques et
bactériologiques je voudrais rencontrer
le premier ingénieur saoudien qui va
diriger ce laboratoire
P4 donc je sais pas je comprends pas la
logique française on est engagé dans un
système d'alliance où on concède à peu
près tout ce que demandent les Saoudiens
même si on sait que
sociologiquement technologiquement
professionnellement ils n'ont pas le
début du cadre ou du premier personnel
pour garder ce genre de truc donc je
sais pas je vous pose trois petites
trois petites questions pour terminer la
première l'asile à Assange qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez ah ben moi je trouve que
c'est inadmissible la façon dont on l'a
traité enfin et à forceuré pour Snowden
c'est-à-dire penser qu'on a interdit un
président d'un État indépendant de
survoler le territoire français parce
qu'on supposait qu'il était peut-être
dans son avion je veux dire qu'on a
rarement été aussi hypocrite et aussi
veul que dans cette décision là et pour
Assange c'estmissible suite au cap de la
de la NSA sur suite au cap de la de la
NSA sur les écoutes du présidentou et
puis pour pour Assange si vous voulez il
nous rend service en nous montrant que
nous sommes écoutés que le président est
écouté il avait montré à à Merkel pour
ce qui concerne l'Allemagne et Cera
qu'on a perdu des marchés à cause de ces
de ses écoutes oui mais ça on le savait
depuis longtemps simplement il en a
apporté la preuve dis c'est une voie
extérieure quand vous perdez un marché
que vous dites évidemment les Américains
on fait on fait ça on vous croit on vous
croit pas là personnalité tierce c'est
lui qui apporte la preuve queon et donc
ça avait cet avantage là mais encore une
fois on est dans une situation où le
type au moins on devrait lui accorder
l'asile politique c'estàdire il est
enfermé aujourd'hui dans l'ambassade
d'Équateur s'en sortir ça fait 2 ans 2
ans et demi qu'il est là-bas et encore
une fois même sil doit être jugé en
Suède il est évident que l'Europe doit
voter une résolution pour qu'il ne soit
pas extradé aux États-Unis qui soit
accusé de quelque chose par les Suédois
je fait confiance à la justice suédoise
mais penser qu'il puisse ensuite être
extradé aux États-Unis bon marqu il est
pas noir donc il sera pas buté dans une
rue c'est déjà ça donc il est blanc donc
il sera jugé il sera condamné à la
prison à perpétuité puce que vous savez
que l'avantage du système américain
c'est on peut être condamné à 375 ans de
prison donc même avec réduction de peine
en général on en sort pas donc ça c'est
ce qui risque de lui passer c'est se
passé c'est ce à quoi été condamné le
jeune soldat qui avait approvisionné
Snowden si vous voulez sur les f BR
Bradley Mannings br ant sur le fond
l'Europe fait preuve d'une indignité
inadmissible sur l'affaire de de Assange
deuxième petite question la parole
diplomatique européenne et la parole
diplomatique française il y a pas de
parole diplomatique européenne d'abord
parce que non parce que regardez il y a
eu deux scénarios dans laquelle dans
lesquels l'Europe s'est totalement
divisé la première c'est l'invasion
américaine en Irak une partie de
l'Europe il va l'autre parti il va pas à
l'honneur de la France la position de
Chirac disant non on na pas c'est une
guerre inadmissible et cetera et cetera
mais vous avez quand même l'Espagne
l'Italie l'Angleterre qui y vont la
suite vous la connaissez c'est les
attentats en Madrid les attentats en
Angleterre donc on devrait réfléchir sur
le passé c'est-à-dire qu'encore une fois
quand un pays s'engage dans une guerre à
l'extérieur il peut y avoir dans sa
propre communauté musulmane des gens qui
sont en désaccord et qui donc légitiment
leur violence terroriste sur place par
le fait que on tue des musulmans là-bas
exemple qui n'a servit à rien puisque de
toute façon nous on s'est engagé dans la
deuxième version de la guerre en Irak
c'est-à-dire celle contre daesh dans
laquelle cette fois les Espagnols les
Italiens ne sont pas allés vous avez
remarqué mais pareil on est dans un
système où l'Europe s'est divisée et
donc il y a pas de parole européenne les
Scandinaves considèrent pas que la
sécurité se joue en Irak Vladimir
Poutine et Vladimir Poutine ben écoutez
c'est un amateur Poutine à côté du roi
d'Arabie Saoudite je veux dire c'est
vrai on a raison de lui donner des
leçons mais sur le fond si on devait
faire un ordre d'abord on commencerait
par George bouche devant la Cour
pénale internationale ensuite dans
descendant si vous voulez dans l'ordre
hiérarchique effectivement on pourrait
éventuellement prendre le roi d'Arabie
Saoudite ou d'autres donc on est dans ce
système extraordinaire par exemple j'ai
vu là récemment sur une dépêche qu'il y
a un des princes saoudiens qui va dédier
sa fortune à faire des actions
humanitaires à améliorer la
compréhension entre les peuples et
cetera je veux dire vous allez discuter
dialogue des cultures avec les Saoudiens
vous je crois pas même que le mot se
traduise en arabe saoudien c'est-à-dire
vous vous allez parler tolérance avec
ces gens-là c'est pas possible donc les
mecs ont de l'argent et ils sont prêts à
raconter n'importe quoi en disant mais
on va financer donc on est dans un
système c'est formidable c'est un un
théâtre d'ombre quoi il faut ils nous
disent un truc on fait semblant d'y
croire on leur répond quelque chose
auquel ils font semblant de croire mais
c'est évident qu'il y a un problème
stratégique majeur qui est celui de
l'évolution de l'Arabie Saoudite son
comportement diplomatique sa réforme
l'ouverture de ces de ces pratiques
cultuelles à l'égard des autres
musulmans et l'arrêt de la de l'espèce
de vous savez les Américains il y a une
ONG américaine qui a regardé par exemple
les manuels d'enseignement saoudien et
notamment dans des écoles qui sont aux
États-Unis puisque ils en ont ouvert
certains et et vous trouvez des phrases
du genre un bon musulman ne doit avoir
aucune relation avec un mécréant non
seulement il doit pas avoir de relation
amicales mais en plus il doit le
détester je vous l' fait bref quoi les
Anglais ont eu le même constat ils ont
constaté dans des écoles Blair qui est
un espèce de faux cul assez étonnant
avait autorisé chacune des communauté à
ouvrir ses propres écoles en disant
diversité culturelle il y a eu des
rapports d'inspection de l'équivalent de
notre inspection de l'éducation
nationale qui se sont faites sur ces
écolesl où ils ont constaté qu'il y
avait séparation des hommes des garçons
et des filles que les non mususulmans
était mis de côté et quand il présentait
comme voyage scolaire le pèlerinage à la
MEC euh et cetera et cetera bon et on on
se dit mais attendez on est parti dans
quelle direction là c'est-à-dire on peut
pas faire croire que ces types sont
respectables vous savez wy Allen
définissait la la liberté de parole ou
la liberté de de oui enfin la liberté de
dans le droit constitutionnel des
démocraties en disant la liberté de
parole c'est pas donneré le même temps
de parole à Hitler à une victime de la
choire or nous on est en train de faire
comme si ce pays parce qu'il a de
l'argent était respectable il ne l' pas
dernière question voilà dernière
question un conseil pour les jeunes
générations écoutez moi j'ai été très
comment dire très agréablement surpris
par ce les gens que j'ai rencontré dans
la Communauté française musulmane parce
que d'abord cette communauté est en
intégration contrairement à ce qu'on
raconte il y a énormément de classes
moyenne musulmane qui sont ingénieurs
techniciens et cetera et cetera et en
particulier il y a beaucoup de jeunes à
qui il faut faire de la place encore une
fois parce qu'il faut leur raconter les
succès stories de cette communauté faut
pas faut pas raconter si vous voulez que
les seuls héros de la communauté sont
les mecs qui sont partis à daesh mais
vous avez des types comme Yazid SABC
comme le président du Racing Club de
Toulon je veux dire ils ont pas ils sont
pas tentés de partir pour daesh donc il
y a encore une fois un rapport avec
cette communauté que je trouve
aujourd'hui important parce que les
attentats terroristes ont modifié
l'ambiance et puis encore une fois c'est
un problème interne aux élites
musulmanes aujourd'hui c'est une guerre
de religion il faut que les types
enseigne la tolérance parce que s'il
l'enseignent pas ils sont en train de se
massacrer entre eux et donc c'est pas la
responsabilité des Américains comme je
l'entends souvent c'est pas la
responsabilité des Français l'examen
critique de cette évolution de l'islam
c'est aux élites musulmanes ou ou aux
Français de culture musulmane de
l'affire il y a des universitaires
français qui le font ces types sont
formidables parce que ils enseignent un
enseignement critique de l'islam toutes
les religions monothéistes ont été
intolérantes premier principe il y a que
mon Dieu qui est le bon c'est la
légitimation du massacre des autres donc
on va pas nous raconter que ceux-là ils
sont plus l'amour et la paix que les
autres non comme toutes les religions
simplement ils ont un décalage de
quelques siècles par rapport à nos
propres GERES de religion c'est-à-dire
qu'ils les font au 21e siècle alors que
nous on les a fait au 17e mais les
conclusions sont les mêmes en général
après un siècle de massacre on découvre
la tolérance pierre connaissa merci
merci
[Musique]